MALE SPEAKER: All right.
I guess we'll get started.
Yeah, very excited to be here.
We have Jon Taffer here
today who many of you know.
Quick background on Jon.
This is from his TV show.
I love the opening.
[ECHOES] Running a bar
is not just a business.
It's a science.
And no one know more about
science than Jon Taffer.
Over the last 36 years,
Jon has transformed
hundreds of failing
bars worldwide.
Using his proven methods
and no nonsense approach,
Jon turns money pits
into money makers.
JON TAFFER: That's pretty good.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
JON TAFFER: I'm not
sure I can top that.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, your
sound guy's awesome.
All right.
But anyway, so Jon is
a very popular host
of the TV show "Bar
Rescue" on Spike TV.
He travels around the
country, finding failing bars
and optimizing them.
He's got a whole science and
strategies and philosophy
on how to optimize a bar.
And at the end, you
know, he leaves the bar
in five days totally changed
and generally successful.
We'll talk about some of
the ones that revert back.
In 2010, he was
appointed president
of the Nightclub
and Bar Media Group.
And then he's recently served
as chairman of Taffer Dynamics,
where he acts as a consultant
to restaurants, nightclubs,
hotels, bars, everything.
And then he just
released his first book,
which is why we're here.
It's called "Raise the Bar.
An Action-based Method for
Maximum Customer Reactions."
And it was published
just a few months ago.
And Jon, like I
said, I'm a huge fan.
So I'm very excited
about this interview.
And a round of applause.
Thank you for being here.
JON TAFFER: Thank you.
Good to be here.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So before we jump into
the book, let's first talk
about kind of your journey.
You started out working in
the restaurant/bar industry.
He even ran Barney's Beanery,
which most people here
know about.
And then you went into
the consulting business.
Can you kind of talk
about that transformation
from working and owning bars to
moving into being a consultant?
JON TAFFER: Sure.
I didn't learn this in college.
I was a political science major.
Very glad I didn't go into
that business, by the way.
But I started tending
bar in college.
And one thing led to another.
And as Jon Lennon
once said "life
is what happens when
you make other plans."
And I wound up being
in the bar business
and started as a bartender.
Became a head bartender,
assistant manager,
general manager.
Moved into the hotel arena.
Became a general manager
of a large resort,
and vice president
of a hotel company.
And in the mid-'80s,
tax codes changed.
And hotels couldn't
write off the deductions
that they used to.
So suddenly, restaurants and
hotels had to make money.
They couldn't be
write-offs anymore.
And the hotel
industry had operated
what I call guest
amenities, not businesses.
So I came in.
And I'm that guy
who signed contracts
with all the big
hotel companies.
I'm the guy who closed
all the restaurants
in the top of hotels
all across the country.
Shut them all down.
I'm the first guy who ever put
a leased restaurant in a Holiday
Inn hotel, which was a
very good idea for them,
and really worked very deeply
bringing brands into hotels
and working in hotel food
and beverage when I started.
I wound up doing about 300
hotels all over the world.
Properties like the Park Hyatt
in Sydney, Grand Hyatt Tokyo,
Taipei, Taiwan,
Jerusalem, London,
and started working all over the
world for the hotel industry.
And my whole purpose
was to teach hoteliers
how to do restaurants
and bars that
could compete against
free standing.
Because in those days,
hotels had no credibility
in that arena.
And that's how I started.
And I started my
consulting company in 1986.
And my first client was the
company that I worked for.
So I left, brought them in.
And then my life changed
when Sheraton came up to me
and offered me a major contract.
And I did 40 Sheraton hotels.
And out of the 40 that I
did, if I remember correctly,
18 of them had the highest sales
per foot in food and beverage
in the entire hotel industry.
And then it all took off for me.
Then, my phone started
ringing off the hook.
In 1991, I opened my first--
actually, that's not correct.
In 1989, I opened the first
operation that I ever owned.
Any Green Bay fans here?
Green Bay Packer fans?
First bar I ever owned was
called Lynn Dickey's Sports
Cafe, who was a quarterback
for Green Bay back then.
And I wound up having
three of those.
And what really
changed my life was
Mall of America in
Minneapolis, which
has more visitations than
the city of Las Vegas.
I opened three restaurants
in Mall of America.
The landlord gave me all the
money-- I opened them for free
and two years later,
was a multimillionaire.
And that really changed my life.
And I'm inspired not by
the bricks and mortar.
I'm not inspired
by the food, even
though it's very important.
I'm inspired by the
look on your face.
That's always been
my inspiration.
I don't believe
that we serve food.
I believe we serve reactions.
We achieve it through food.
I don't believe we play music.
We play reactions.
We achieve it through food.
And I don't believe
you guys sell ads.
The fact of the matter is if the
viewer doesn't react to the ad,
the ad is meaningless.
We don't sell ads.
We sell reactions.
We achieve it through
ads, whether they're
client reactions, whether
they're advertiser reactions
or prospect reactions.
And that's what I
learned at a young age.
And that philosophy
changed my life.
And by understanding
the principle
of reaction management--
I own that term.
I actually own the term
"reaction management"--
everything changed for me.
And suddenly I
realized that wow,
I can cause you to do things
you wouldn't normally do.
I can manipulate the hell
out of you if I want to.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: Make
you buy what I want
you to, go where I want you
to, sit where I want you to.
So I became a nut case
on human behavior.
And things really puzzle me.
For example, 70% of all
people that walk into a mall
make a right hand turn.
Why?
That -- excuse me--
that shit haunts me.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: It does!
And it makes me say, what can
I do to make you make a left?
And I will lay awake at
night figuring out ways
to make you make that left turn.
And that's very
rewarding to me when
I can change human behavior.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you think
that's because 90% of people
are right-handed?
JON TAFFER: I'm not sure.
I'm a lefty.
So I couldn't relate to that.
But no, I'm not sure that is.
There's an inherent
movement towards the right.
Maybe it's because we
bear right on roads.
Maybe we even bear right when
we walk through airports.
So maybe that's the principle.
But it's interesting,
when you go to Asia,
and they walk into a mall, they
make a right hand turn too.
So I'm not sure that
argument holds water.
But there are certain
things about human behavior
that are shocking to me.
And there's gold, when
you can change behavior.
Walt Disney was
the master of it.
You go to Walt Disney
World in Orlando.
It's 120 degrees.
You're sweating like crazy.
You spent $90 to walk
through the door.
Within three minutes,
you're standing
on line for an hour and a half.
Right?
You get off the line, you
go through an attraction
for two minutes.
You get on another line
for an hour and a half.
After three lines in five
hours, you've done three things.
Now you want a Coke.
So you stand online for
45 minutes for that.
Now you get a cup with
Mickey Mouse on it.
Now you got to carry this thing
around with you all day long.
$14.95.
And you realize when you go
home with the bags of stuff
you'll never use, the
T-shirt you'll never wear,
you realize wow!
I sweated, I stood in
line, and I loved it.
And there's a manipulative
quality to business.
And you're no different.
When we cause people
to act in ways
that enhance our objectives,
not theirs, we all make money.
So the trick is how
do I get you to do
what isn't natural to you,
but have you love me for it
in the end?
That's the trick.
Because I want you to
come back and do it again.
Right?
There's no such thing as single
transactions in the world.
Everything is
multiple transactions.
I'm all about getting to
that next transaction.
That's what's important to me.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So we heard a lot
about your consulting.
How did the TV show come
about with Spike TV?
Did you initiate it?
Did they initiate it?
JON TAFFER: I did.
I'm very proud of this.
I've been a public speaker in
my industry for about 30 years.
And I give keynote speeches.
And I get a lot of
money for speeches.
I've spoken in about 30
countries around the world.
And I'll speak in major
industry conventions.
I'm speaking at Friday's next
week for their corporate event.
And I was giving a
speech in Las Vegas,
and somebody came up to me
and said, you should be on TV.
And I thought about it.
So I went home, and
I wrote something up,
which was originally
called "On the Rocks."
And I came out here and
went to Hermosa Beach
to a friend that owned a bar.
I got a camera, a microphone,
and I got his employees
to work with me.
And I did a three
minutes sizzle reel.
And really it was me
just screaming at people.
I just walked into
his bar, screamed
and yelled at the employees.
"Not negotiable!
You're fired!" and
there's this whole thing.
And I didn't know
anybody in Hollywood.
I was a bar guy.
And so I had this three
minutes sizzle reel.
I sent it cold to five
companies and got three offers--
and it was unbelievable--
within a week.
And I had offers from three
different production companies.
So I had a look at each
company, do background checks,
and the company I picked
was the best one, but not
necessarily the
best financial deal.
So I thought more long
term than short term.
I signed with 3 Ball Productions
in Manhattan Beach, who
also does "Biggest Loser" and
one of the largest reality
show producers.
They picked me up,
signed me to a contract,
and Spike picked up the
show four days later.
So in the time I got the
idea, to the premiere
of the show on
TV-- not the pilot,
the first season--
was less than a year.
And I'm told that's
almost a record.
And normally, it takes
two to three years
to get to that level.
So I was blessed, I think.
Some of that's timing.
I get that I'm pretty
good at what I do.
But some of it is timing.
I just happened to be in the
right place at the right time,
I think.
So the show premiered
almost three years ago.
We just aired our 49th
episode to the highest ratings
in the history of the show.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
JON TAFFER: Thank you.
Honestly, it's been an
incredibly humbling experience
for me.
And I'm shocked when celebrities
get these egos that suddenly
you're unimportant to them.
They're above you.
It has made me appreciate
humanity, the people around me
that support me, believe in me.
This has actually made
me a better person.
And I wouldn't have
thought about it that way
before the fact.
But it has humbled me.
I feel like I'm hugged
by America every day.
It's an incredible feeling.
MALE SPEAKER: That's great.
And so 49 episodes-- how do you
decide which bars to rescue?
I'm sure you've got
a ton of requests
from bars all over the country.
And you've done all
over the country.
And some are really awful.
And some are just
horrific, like,
how do you decide which to--
JON TAFFER: That's my choice.
Awful or horrific.
It's pretty accurate too.
Actually, when I did the
show, my deal with the network
was I wanted you to find
me the worst in the world.
I don't want this
to be a cake walk.
I want to fail.
So now that we're
known, about 1,000 bars
submit applications
a year for me
to scream at them,
which is amazing to me.
And these are people
that are in trouble.
So we go through a
screening process.
First of all, we picked the
cities that make sense to us.
We like small towns, big
towns, Midwest, East Coast.
We like to move it
around and mix it up,
so we have the
different subcultures
of America, if you
will, in a show.
The next thing we do is
we see if they're real.
Are they hustling
me for a remodel?
Or are they really in debt?
Are there really
houses on the line?
Is this a real story?
So we verify those elements.
We verify the debt,
all that kind of stuff.
Make sure that there
are stakes, if you will.
Then, once we've narrowed
it down to about 40 or 50,
then I'll send a
producer to each
of those locations with
just a little camera.
And they'll talk to each staff
member for about 20 seconds.
That's all.
What's your name?
What do you here?
What do you think of this place?
What's your name?
What do you do?
So we can see the
behavior of the employees.
And I'm looking for
a compelling story,
I want you rooting for the
owner or hating the owner.
But I want you connected to it.
And the secret of "Bar Rescue"
is finding those personalities
that are exciting to be with.
And if you think it's
frustrating to watch,
you should live it, Because
it's quite an experience.
Very
MALE SPEAKER: Very cool.
And what would you
say is the number one
reason most bars fail.
JON TAFFER: Excuses.
But that's the reason why
all of you would fail too.
And here it is.
You wake up in the morning.
You're failing.
So you blame the President.
You blame Congress.
You blame Greece.
Blame the Euro.
I mean, construction
industry-- it's the Mayor!
Oh, it's the this.
And you wake up in the morning,
and you look in the mirror.
And you're not failing, because
it's the other guy's fault.
Or it's the economy's fault.
But if you looked in
the mirror and said
I'm failing because I'm
me, you wouldn't like it.
And you'd change that.
And I believe the
common denominator
of failure in any
business is excuses.
As long as you wake up
and blame poor sales
on the economy or
an environment, then
you have no motivation
to make it better,
because it's not your fault.
But in the worst
economic environment,
four, five years in this
country, ago, in this country
that we've seen,
in our lifetimes,
there were people making a
lot of money, weren't there?
In the height of
that recession, there
were people selling advertising,
people opening restaurants,
people building businesses.
Somebody's making money.
So the excuse is bull.
It's bull.
So wake up in the morning
and own your failure.
Look in the mirror and say
I'm failing because of me!
And you won't like it.
And then you'll change it.
But as long as you
don't put it on you,
you have no motivation
to change it.
So in short, if you
own your failure,
you'll own your success.
If you don't own your
failure, you'll never dig out.
And I find that in any business.
Always the common
denominator of failure,
personally, is excuses.
You don't want to be
a failure, do you?
AUDIENCE: Not at all.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: You don't
want to look in the mirror
and experience that.
If you can't blame
anybody but yourself,
you're going to change.
You're going to fight it out.
That's the deal.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So a lot of guys in this
room want to open bars,
like this one sitting up
here in the front row.
What do you say to
these people that
want to open their
own bar one day.
JON TAFFER: Well, first
of all, know your reason.
Anybody see the Murphy's
episode of "Bar Rescue"?
The two frat brothers
opened a bar?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
JON TAFFER: The last
thing you want to do
is open a bar because
you like to drink.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: That's like
somebody into drugs
who becomes a pharmacist.
I mean that's just--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: It makes
no sense at all.
You got do it for
the right reasons.
You've got to do it because
you love the business.
If you love the
social aspect of it,
you'll never do your financials.
You'll just hang with
people all day long.
If you love the drinking,
that's even worse.
You got to love the business.
It's a tough business.
And we were talking before we
started, in the clothing store
business, you buy shirts.
You mark them up 60%, 70%.
If you got 10
shirts on the shelf,
you go home that night, you
come back in the morning,
you still got 10
shirts on a shelf.
Not the bar business.
Bar business, you've got
to manage every minute.
Product is exposed.
Liabilities are exposed.
It's a tough business.
Honestly, if I had
to do it over again,
I'm not sure I would
be in this business.
To be honest with you,
when I look at all the work
that I did over
the years, I could
have applied those efforts
to bigger things rather than
smaller bars.
And I was involved in
Rainforest Cafe, for example.
That went public, and
it was big dollars.
Don't get me wrong.
I don't regret being
in the bar business.
But when I look at my life,
all the nights that I worked,
all those evenings,
days, 20-hour days,
I look back and say gee, wonder
if I would have been a lawyer.
Nah, maybe not a lawyer.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: No!
JON TAFFER: There are lifestyles
that are easier is my point.
So you've got to
love the business
and be passionate
about it to make it
through those late nights
and those mornings.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
And what's been the
hardest "Bar Rescue"
you've ever done and why?
JON TAFFER: I'm going to guess
the hardest "Bar Rescue" I've
ever done was the one
that aired-- actually,
the last one with
the two twins, which
aired just about
three weeks ago,
where I had a family--
I mean, these guys
hadn't had Christmas dinner
together in nine years.
They lived across from
each other, these twins,
and they hated each other.
And what I learned
about "Bar Rescue"
is it's so about the people.
And at the end of the day,
I got those twins together.
It was a pretty intense episode.
And I don't know
if any of you saw
that episode-- the
son Tyler, the nephew,
sent me a note that they had
their best Christmas dinner
in all these years
for the family.
So when you have
personalities that don't work,
that's the challenge.
I can paint the bar.
I know how to set it up.
I know how to put
the technology in it.
I know how to decorate it.
I know how to program.
The people--
remember these people
aren't failing
because of their bars.
They're failing because of them.
And that's my challenge.
And that was a
particularly good one.
And I'm going to answer
the next question for you.
The best one we've
ever done is probably
"Spirits on Bourbon," which was
the first episode this season.
They're up $125,000 a month.
AUDIENCE: Holy shit!
JON TAFFER: The
barber shop chair
is the most photographed
attraction on Bourbon Street.
Last month, it did over
$80,000-- just that chair.
And the guys, they
sent me a note.
They've become good friends.
They just bought a
warehouse, so they
can buy cups for their
Resurrection cocktails, 20,000
at a time to keep
their prices down.
And it's to me-- I'm not
always right in life.
None of us are.
But I'm pretty close.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: When it comes
to the bar business.
People, when they stay with the
plan, tend to do really well.
"Moon Runners"--
MALE SPEAKER: Yup.
JON TAFFER: Which is from
your neck of the wood.
I mean, their
numbers are up 600%.
And there's an independent
website-- forgive me,
I forget the name.
Bar Rescue something--
that somebody does,
and they track them all.
And I believe on their site--
and I haven't been there
in a few weeks-- on their
site, we had aired 47 of 48.
They claim that seven closed.
And I don't count.
So I'm going to take
them at face value.
But what they did is they
did Before and After Yelp.
And then they tell you if
it's opened and closed.
So 48 or 49 episodes are there.
If seven have
closed, that puts us
in about an 80% track record.
And when you consider the depth
of failure these people are in,
I'm pretty proud of that.
I'm not sure we could do much
better, to tell you the truth.
But the pirates episode
has to be mentioned.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: Only because it
was the most bizarre experience
of my life.
These people were pirates.
They couldn't speak un-pirate.
They couldn't talk like we do.
They spoke like 1845 pirates.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: They didn't
have regular clothes.
These people woke up every
morning to be pirates.
And when I said to them how
how do you make a living?
Oh, Renaissance Faire.
That's two weeks a year.
Oh, no, there's a
big pirate community.
I go on Facebook.
200 people.
And these people
wanted to be pirates.
And if you remember, when I
put them in regular clothes,
they couldn't speak non-pirate.
So I guess let them play in
their sandbox, so to speak.
But that was a very
frustrating one for me,
because a Discovery TV
was right next door.
There were huge office
buildings in Silver Spring.
The concept that we created
was for lunch and happy hour,
for them to close
early, because at night,
that was a dangerous,
not a very good area.
They never even
opened for lunch.
They tore the sign down
six hours after I left.
It's on YouTube.
A vigil around a fire, where
they were chanting, of course,
pirate songs.
And it was one of the most
bizarre experiences of my life.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: I will
never forget it.
And they're still
open, by the way,
which is unbelievable to me.
MALE SPEAKER: So you actually
kind of just referenced this.
I know a couple
people in the crowd
had asked me this ahead of time.
But a lot of people
watch your show,
and then they get on Yelp
immediately following,
and see whether it's
been successful or not.
And several times, we've seen
them change the name back.
They reverted back
to their bad ways.
Other people have
kept what you've
done or remained successful.
Can you kind of
talk about why is it
that some have
reverted and failed,
while others keep what
you've given them, et cetera.
JON TAFFER: Yeah, good question.
These people make
thousands of bad decisions
that got me there.
Right?
Think of all the
choices that they
made from hiring to
products to management
to cause them to be in
the depth of failure
that they're in when I show up.
And my challenge is
to reverse that level
of failure, that
depth of failure.
I forgot your question.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh,
it was just why
do some revert back to their
old name and [INAUDIBLE].
JON TAFFER: So what happens
is-- and I'll pick one.
The Brixton in Austin, Texas.
Remember that one?
With the cocky husband--
they changed the name back
a week later.
But they kept everything else.
They kept the
infusion cocktails.
But they were hung
up on The Brixton.
They're doing pretty well.
But guys, you know this.
If the Google name had
a terrible association
with it and a reputation
for not delivering
on the promises made, how much
advertising would you sell?
So if I didn't
change the company,
but put a new sign
on the building,
at least I have a
chance at a new future.
So, Swanky Bubbles--
remember that one?
Who puts Swanky Bubbles
back on a building.
You think you would thank
you for taking it down.
But they changed the
name back the next day.
And his logic was
it's confusing.
My old customers won't
come to the new bar.
You were losing money
with the old customers.
And here's what they
don't understand.
When they changed the
name back, they're
thinking of the
customers they have.
I'm trying to get them to
customers they don't have
and the thousands of people that
they alienated and chased away.
So with a new brand
comes a honeymoon.
With a new brand comes
a whole new future.
I have probably kept as
many brands as I've changed.
So I don't just go in
there and change the brand.
We do a lot of market research.
I use Esri.
And I do all my online research.
By the way, "Bar Rescue"
is absolutely in real time.
I should speak to
this for a moment.
You know, the first day
I show up at about 4:35
in the afternoon.
I go in and do my
recon that night.
When I leave the bar that
night, that day ends for me.
I go back to my hotel.
The next day is Day 2.
We train, we have stress test.
The next day is Day 3 training.
At the end of Day 3,
at about 9 o'clock,
I get the staff out
of there at night.
And then we go to
work building the bar.
We do it for a true 36 hours.
So the evening of Day
3, the day of Day 4,
and the morning of Day
5, we remodel the bar.
And then I reveal
it to them on Day 5.
It is absolutely in real
time, and not one word of it
is scripted ever.
Candidly, if it
was, I'd walk off.
And I just won't do that.
So it is incredibly real.
And that's why the
casting, the selection
of the bars and the
characters are so important,
because I'm not
going to script it.
And in "Bar
Rescue," we use the phrase
"we work with what we have.
We don't create
what we don't have."
And it's working the moment.
And we've gotten pretty good at
it, I think, after 59 of them
or so.
MALE SPEAKER: Man.
So why did you decide
to write a book.
JON TAFFER: I've been a
public speaker for 30 years.
I love helping people.
I can't tell you-- you know, I
tell people this story often.
One of the greatest moments
in my life was an operator.
When I opened Mall of
America, it had a dishwasher.
His name was Theo.
And this guy was a
dishwasher, almost
a gang banger kind of
kid in Minneapolis.
And my prep cook quit, and
I made him a prep cook.
I liked this kid
for some reason.
Then I'm opening another
restaurant six months later.
And I pick a training
team from that restaurant
and I fly them to another city.
And I took Theo as
my prep cook trainee.
And now we're in a hotel
meeting room, sort of like this.
And all my training
team goes up in front
of the staff to
introduce themselves.
And Theo walks out there
in a shark skin suit,
missing his teeth and
gold in the front,
and says six months
ago, I was a dishwasher.
And look at me today.
And I cried.
And I realized that was the
most important thing to me
I could ever do.
And I've been
fortunate in my life.
I've made money.
Now I want to make people.
And I'm really inspired by that.
And we talked
about this earlier,
when people come up to me and
say they've gotten promoted,
I've inspired them, they've
raised the bar, whatever
it is it's an incredibly
motivating thing to me.
So the book was an
effort to do that,
to try to take what I do and
share it with more people,
because I really believe in it.
MALE SPEAKER: Very cool.
And so your philosophy
of reaction management
which you coined is kind of the
main theme throughout the book.
Can you give everyone a quick
summary of what that is?
JON TAFFER: Sure.
First, let me explain
how it came about,
because I don't cover it
very much in the book.
When I was young, my mother
was incredibly difficult,
a little violent.
So when I was seven,
eight, nine, ten years old,
I understood that if I
couldn't control her mood,
I was going to
get my ass kicked.
So at a very young age,
I learned the sensitivity
to watch her face,
read her moods.
And I developed this skill
to sense and feel people.
Like your crossed arm, right?
I would stare at you
and shake my head
until those arms uncrossed.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: Same with you.
I mean, I look at
everybody's body language.
And I do it subliminally.
I don't think about
it consciously.
Your eye contact, your body
language, your energy level,
your posture.
And I read these things.
And I figured out how
to manipulate you.
And here's a philosophy.
If you go into a
restaurant and you sit down
and you order food.
And the food comes to the table,
and it's put down on a table.
When the plate hits the table--
and this could be anything.
It could be a Google ad--
one of two things happens.
Either the guest sits up, reacts
to it, or nothing happens.
If nothing happens, we're
stuck in mediocrity the rest
of our lives.
Whether that's a Google Ad,
whether it's a plate of food,
whether it's a song, whether
it's the color of a wall,
nothing we do is anything other
than creating human reactions.
When reactions go in the
direction we want them to,
people write us
checks, don't they?
They move to other
sides of the country.
They take jobs.
Everything changes,
when we can cause
people to react in the
ways that we need to.
So at a young age, I
developed this skill.
And that's why I think
"Bar Rescue" works
for me because I'm only
with these people five days.
I got to read them quick.
And we were talking earlier--
I mean, I'm people's faces,
for sure-- but
there's a reason why.
This might surprise you.
I am never angry
on "Bar Rescue."
It is completely calculated.
It is completely deliberate.
And we were talking, if
I wanted to pick on him,
OK, this is a guy
with some pride.
First, I'm going to try pride.
Do you want to be a success?
Do you want to be a failure?
What are your parents going to
say when they see you faiiling?
I'll try, that didn't work.
Now, I'll try fear.
You're going to lose everything!
You're going to be
out in the street.
What are you gon--
that didn't work.
Picture your kids.
Can you come true for your kids?
That didn't work.
Well, now I have
only one option.
I'm going to rip you to shreds.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: Because
I have no choice.
And here is "Bar Rescue" in
its most essence, if you will,
right at the core.
You're going to
dig your heels in.
And you're not
going to let me in.
You're going to get defensive.
So I'm going to be in your face.
I am going to be
relentless, until I
can make you doubt
yourself for one second.
And if I can make
you doubt yourself
just a little for one
second, your brain opens
and I walk right the hell in.
And that's the way it is.
I got to break you down and
make you doubt yourself.
Because you're the
one who's wrong.
You're the one losing money.
I've got the bank
accounts to prove it.
So I stand there with
this cocky, confidence.
And I will beat and
beat and beat on you
until that crap comes open.
And then I walk in, and we
were talking before I started,
the biggest fights
I have are always
the biggest hugs at
the end, aren't they?
So when you turn them,
you really turn them.
It's an incredible
thing to watch.
And they walk different
four days later.
Once I crack through,
their posture's different.
Their facial expression
is different.
When you look in your
eye, you can truly
see this human transformation.
It's remarkable.
And you see it on TV, but
it's even more evident
when you're there.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
Very cool.
So a lot of people in this
room work in advertising.
You talk about
advertising in the book.
Can you talk about what
sort of advertising bars
can do from digital to-- you
talk a lot about word of mouth
too, whether that can
be something generated.
JON TAFFER: Sure.
Let me start by saying I come
from an advertising background.
My grandfather
invented Direct Mail.
And gets credit for inventing
Direct Mail in Brooklyn, New
York.
When he was 16 years old,
he bought a printing press,
and started putting
fliers in newspaper
at the newspaper
stand on the corner.
And then he walked
down the street
and wrote down the
names in the mailboxes
and started leaving
flyers in the apartment
buildings in Brooklyn.
And then, he started
getting and mailing them
from this little
storefront that he had.
And one of the largest
ad companies in the world
knew we were advertising,
bought my grandfather's
little storefront
operation, brought him in.
The term Direct
Marketing was invented.
And my grandfather then
created the entire direct
marketing/direct mail.
And my family has done
the direct marketing
for Volvo, Mercedes Benz,
and a bunch of companies
now for three generations.
So I come from a
marketing background.
It's in my blood.
And to me, marketing is
just human reactions.
Period.
End the discussion.
We don't do ads.
We do human reactions.
We achieve them through ads.
I don't even make phone calls.
I create human reactions.
I do it on the phone.
The fact of the
matter is everything
I do-- no different
than this moment
right now-- if I don't
create reactions, I fail.
Period, and so do you.
So it's a way of life.
You study every facial
expression, every inflection
in voices, everything
to manipulate you
for me to get your check.
I have no guilt doing that,
because I know when you give me
a check, I'm going to come
through for you in the end.
That's the trick.
When you know you're doing
right you can fight harder.
You got to know
you're doing right.
You guys do right here.
You're a great company.
I advertise on Google myself.
But I've learned that if an
ad doesn't create a reaction,
it's worthless.
And where we blow
it, in that business,
is when we take advertising
dollars from a client
and place an ad that we know
is not going to get a reaction,
that we know is going to fail.
We don't serve them.
We don't get a renewal.
We don't serve our
ourselves and our company.
So the end result is you
guys have to create reactions
from the advertising
that you do.
Or you're never going
to grow that business.
So you're as much in the
reaction business as I am.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
Very cool.
And so a lot of us,
we love the parts
of the show when you really
dig deep into the science
behind the bar, the science
of everything that you do.
And it's all to increase
workplace efficiency
and whatnot.
Google prides itself on
trying to do the same things.
So what are some
of the sciences you
learned to optimize for
workplace efficiency.
JON TAFFER: You know, there's
a lot of things to it.
And I want to
reiterate the question
that you asked me before.
You asked me about
social marketing,
and I didn't mention it.
You know, social marketing
is a big word today.
And everybody does it.
But who does it well?
Not too many.
It's a new science.
We're still figuring
it out ourselves.
I mean, just because I have
100,000 Twitter followers,
how do I monetize that?
How do I motivate these people?
What is it?
Is it an event?
Is it a discount?
I mean, what is it
that causes people
to-- and I'm going
to use my word--
react to my social marketing?
No reaction, no dollars.
No reaction, no win.
So where people
blow it is they go
through the mechanics
of social marketing.
They go through the
mechanics of advertising,
but they never really focus
on "where are the reactions?"
And here's the way I say it.
And I'm trying to be short.
You know, in the real world,
when a big company goes
to an ad agency,
and the ad agency
provides all the creative.
If you like the creative,
you buy the advertising.
If you don't like the creative,
you don't buy the advertising.
Bar business?
Opposite.
We buy the advertising
with no creative,
and then at the last
minute we get a phone call.
I need your copy.
Oh, oh!
And so the fact of
the matter is we
go at it in a mechanical way.
And that's what you can't do.
You've got to make certain that
those reactions are created.
The words, the phrasing,
the fonts, the color,
the positioning--
these are subliminals
that will either somebody
to click through or not.
And you are a point
of difference.
You guys stand alone.
You're the shining
star in the business.
Nobody lights a candle to you.
Bing?
Come on.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: The fact
that the matter is now
because you are perceived as
so good at what you do, so big,
the bar is high, isn't it?
Now I expect more
from you, which
means as we get bigger and
better and our reputation
grows, we've got to
deliver stronger.
So the problem with
social marketing
is an absence of
creative generally.
It's become more
mechanical, more logistical,
very uncreative.
And some of it is because
it's in real time.
In a newspaper ad, you
plan a month ahead of time,
two months ahead of time.
You work on your copy work.
Social marketing, I
come up with it today.
I put it online in 10 minutes.
There is no planning.
And the real time nature of
it sometimes works against us.
And then here's the
ultimate kicker.
When I hit you with
social marketing
three or four times
in a row and blow it,
you're going to delete me
every time for then on.
I'll never get you back.
So we only have one shot.
I believe in social marketing.
Either we engage the audience.
Either we connect
with the audience.
Or we alienate the
audience and we will never
connect with them after that.
And that's what my
experiences are.
MALE SPEAKER: Nice.
And some of the
big shock moments
of the show and
when fire people.
And sometimes you get in their
face and you throw them out.
Other times, you're sympathetic.
You're like, sorry,
I have to let you go.
So how do you choose
like you're going to fire
and how you do it?
And you're welcome
to practice on me
if you want to fire me
[INAUDIBLE] interview.
JON TAFFER: Well,
you know, when you
were talking earlier about
general marketing sciences.
The bar business is very visual.
I need to move your eye
where I needed to go.
First, I sell with the eye, then
I get my hand into your pocket.
So I say, with the
exterior building.
If I don't pull your eye, I'm
not going to pull your body.
The front door of a business.
If I don't pull your eye, I'm
not going to pull your body.
In a Google ad, if I
don't pull your eye,
the copy doesn't mean anything.
So the fact of
the matter is I've
got to connect and pull you in.
And there's all
sorts of sciences.
When you walk in the
front door of a business,
your eyes are going to go to the
most colorful or brightest spot
in a room.
Every time.
End of discussion.
So some designer puts a
beautiful piece of artwork
on the wall.
I'm not making money off that.
No!
Put the artwork over there.
I'm putting what I make money
on, where the eye falls.
So one of the
things that do is I
work very hard on
changing eye movement when
you walk through the door.
I also know that bars
are about meeting people.
Eye contact.
So at zero level, in a
bar when it's unelevated,
everybody's at high seating.
So everybody's eyes are within
10 inches of each other,
whether you're standing
or sitting in a bar stool.
When people connect, the
magic of a bar happens.
But you've got to look
at each other's eyes
or it never starts.
So in elevated areas
in bars, there's
a lot of science to this.
If I have one staircase on
an elevation in a bar, what
happens is you see a
pretty girl up there.
So you go up the steps, you
walk, you hit a dead end.
You feel like an idiot.
You got to turn around
and go back the other way.
And she knows exactly
what you're doing.
So you never go up there again.
But with two staircases, I
walk through with a purpose
and go out the other side.
So it's totally manipulative
in every conceivable way.
I want to manipulate
where your eyes go,
which way you go, where
you sit, where you stand.
And here's the trick
to the bar business.
You can make drinks
at home, can't you?
You don't need me for cocktails.
You can make exactly
what you want.
In today's world,
the technology--
we can get exactly the
programming that I want,
musically, video,
satellite, online.
I have every entertainment
option and everything
I could ever want at home.
I don't need you for drinks.
I don't need you
for entertainment.
There's one thing that you
can't get at home that I have.
And that's social interaction.
That's my calling card.
And if I create socially
interactive environments,
people come back.
And that's where these sciences
play in of height and eye
movement and all
of these things.
It's all about
creating interaction.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So we'll do one last question.
And then we'll open up to
the floor for questions.
So you just finished
Season 3 of "Bar Rescue."
You just wrote your book.
What is next for Jon Taffer?
I have a new show I'm
starting in February
called "The Hungry Investor."
And I describe it as a
cross between "Bar Rescue,"
"Hell's Kitchen,"
and "Shark Tank."
Myself and two
partners are traveling
around the country looking
for businesses to invest in.
So let's say, we decide
we want to invest
in steak houses or
any business-- sushi,
whatever it might be.
So we might come to LA,
pick two steak houses
that we might want to invest in.
And I created this formula
called an Invest Test. where
we determine the elasticity
and potential of the business
and individuals in it.
So we run them through this
rigorous and best test process
to determine there in
your business's potential.
And then at the
end of the show, we
determine which one we're
going to invest in it,
and we give him the money.
And we make the investment.
And then we let you
know how it did.
So it's much more business
return on investment, equity,
a little deeper for me.
It's sort of fun.
It allows me to show my
business knowledge, not just
my bar knowledge.
I'm excited about it.
Then "Bar Rescue,"
I told you we just
got picked up just yesterday.
20 more episodes
for us is Season 5.
So I'm very excited about that.
MALE SPEAKER: Congratulations.
JON TAFFER: I just finished
my 59th episode yesterday.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
All right, let's
open it to questions.
And there's actually a
microphone right over there
that we can--
AUDIENCE: So if you had
a room full of people,
what would you tell them
in a brief period of time
to keep them from ever
showing up on your show?
JON TAFFER: No excuses.
If I had to leave
you with one message,
it's understanding that
all I'm going to do
is identify where
you're failing.
You can do that too if you want.
But you got to
look at the mirror
and say I'm failing because of
me-- what am I doing wrong--
And pick it apart.
The other thing about
the bar business
is I've seen a lot of bars not
fail, but run out of money.
They would've turned the corner.
The first restaurant
I ever owned by myself
was called Alamo Grill.
Actually, second one.
And Lynn Dickey was the first.
And I opened it, and
about 90 days into it,
I ran out of money.
I was losing money
in Mall of America.
And it's because it
was a new business,
and we were so busy that I
couldn't make it profitable.
So I was in trouble.
So I went and sold
50% of this business
that I put a million
dollars in for $150,000
to get the money I needed.
That year, that business
profited $800,000,
and somebody else owned
half of it for $150,000.
It's almost like
a football game.
Vince Lombardi once said,
I never lose the game.
I just run out of time.
That's very much
the bar business.
If you just had the money
for another month or two,
you could've figured
it out and made it.
And the problem with the bar
business is it's all rookies.
There's no place where you'd
go and learn the bar business.
There's hospitality schools.
There's no bar school.
So the bar sciences that
I teach-- Google it!
There's nobody else who
teaches these things.
There's no other books
with these things
that teach these sciences.
So the fact of the matter is I'm
a little unique in what I do,
but every bar can be
successful, if they just
changed what they do.
And I'll leave you with
a quote from, I believe,
Benjamin Franklin.
It says "if you do tomorrow,
what you did today,
you'll get tomorrow
which you got today."
I got to make them do
something different tomorrow.
So do they.
And the strange thing is they
could do that without me.
But the problem is they
blame the president,
they blame Congress, they blame
everything else but themselves.
And then they go home,
mad at somebody else.
I suggest you should go
home mad at yourself.
MALE SPEAKER: Great
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Where did you get a
lot of the data and statistics
you use, such as
if you serve food,
someone stays 45 minutes longer.
If you have neon lights, they
leave 30 minutes earlier.
Where do you get that data?
JON TAFFER: Some of
that is industrial.
For example, the fluorescent
lighting is industrial.
It was actually a study done
by General Motors years ago,
where they changed
florescent lighting
to incandescent lighting.
And illnesses went down.
And employee
productivity went up.
And I own a company
called GuestProbe.
And it's not a company
that I promote publicly,
but I have over my 30 years,
I have these databases
with 60,000 restaurants
and bars worth of data,
where I've done these
surveys and focus groups.
So most of this data is owned by
me, really, and created by me.
It's a little unique.
And it's not out
there any place else.
So for me, I know
it's 52 minutes,
because I've tracked
it for 30 years.
Nobody else has.
I wish I had a better
answer for you.
But that's the reality of it to.
They're my own sciences
that I test and work.
And they work every
time for me, as you see.
When I push the
buttons, it happens.
Science is science, but I'm the
nutcase who does this stuff.
And I am.
I'm a nutcase on this stuff.
I will spend a fortune
to build a video camera
in the corner behind
a piece of mirror,
just so that I can
monitor posture.
When I open a new
bar or restaurant,
I put a girl in the ladies'
room in a stall with a notepad.
And she sits in there
for an hour and a half
because what you guys say
to each other at the mirror
is gospel.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: I want to know.
I want to know what you're
saying to each other.
When do you think of my food?
What do you think
of my environment?
Do you think the place is safe?
Do you like the other customers?
I need to know.
I have this insatiable
addictive need
to know what's going
on in your brain.
So I use every trick in the
book to get to that information.
So it's 30-year, $60,000
restaurants worth of data.
It's actually a
really neat database,
even down to the color of
plates, flow patterns, hours,
price, points, for example,
psychological pricing.
And there's no difference
in guest perception
from $8.25 or $8.95.
Absolutely zero.
So if you charge $8.25 instead
of $8.95, you're leaving what?
60 cents on a table every
time you create a transaction.
So I can go into a bar, just
change the pricing from $8.50
to $8.95 on all the menu
items, move some stuff around,
not change one recipe and
increase revenues by about 20%.
So that's the science.
I can box something in
the center of a menu
and sales of that item will
go up 20% every single time.
If I bold it, put
Chef's Special on it,
sales would go up 14% to
17% every single time.
People have a 6.5%
propensity to order
the top bottom and bottom two
items on the list on a menu.
So what am I going to do?
I'm going to take my
most profitable item,
box it, shadow it, move it
all around, move it at $8.95,
and manipulate you to buy
what I'm making money on.
If there's a menu item
that my customers love,
that I don't make
money on, I hide it,
so no new customer find it.
The old customers know I got it.
I'm not going to take
it away from you.
But I don't want anybody else
getting hooked with this thing.
I want them [CLICKING SOUND].
So I hide that in the menu, and
move my most profitable items.
It's incredibly manipulative.
And I had the confidence to do
this because of that database.
Or I probably wouldn't
have the confidence
to make the bold moves
that I do sometimes.
MALE SPEAKER: And what is the
name of that invention where
you have the two rails
with just a limited space?
JON TAFFER: Butt funnel.
Made a lot of money, a lot of
mileage, off the butt fun--
the concept of the
butt funnel, and it's
for a youthful, high
energy nightclub.
It's a narrow entryway
to a dance floor.
So stand up for a second.
So if we're going to
go in this dance floor,
we got to sort of go like this.
Now, with a guy and
a girl, it tends
to work better most
of the time, but--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: The
fact is I'm forcing
their faces to be together.
I'm forcing eye contact.
I'm forcing human interaction.
And butt funneling, I
invented about 25 years ago.
Got a lot of mileage
out of the butt funnel.
MALE SPEAKER: That's great.
All right, next question.
AUDIENCE: OK, well, first I have
to say, sorry, that I actually
never watch your show,
which I have to start.
But it sounds like,
from your story,
that the first thing that
the owner does is like, oh,
I don't want to change.
So I'm curious what your take
on this human psychology.
On the one hand, they
obviously apply for the show,
and they know they're going
to be asked for a change.
But then they don't
want to change.
JON TAFFER: You know,
it's interesting,
when I look at those five
minute little casting reels
that we do, they say stuff
like oh, when Taffer gets here,
he's going to love me.
I mean he's going to think that
I'm as good at this as he is.
Boy, do they get a
surprise when I show up.
Then the other guy says, oh,
boy, if he screams at me,
I'm going to go at him.
I just look at him loudly,
and he starts crying.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JON TAFFER: So they
take this posture.
It's strange.
And after shooting
59 of them, you'd
think they know what's coming.
But the fact of the
matter is each one of them
thinks that they're going
to be the one that I'm not
going to scream at.
And if you saw Gypsy, the Las
Vegas gay bar that we did,
remember what he says?
Oh, I got to tell you.
Jon is going to be my buddy.
And then after this
is all done, he's
going to go out for a drink,
and he's going to say,
Paul, you were right,
and I was wrong.
Yeah, that didn't quite work
out for him as he thought.
But it's fascinating, that
human dynamic that you're
setting yourself up
to be embarrassed
on national television.
And here's the
unique part of it.
At the end of the show,
they're not really embarrassed,
are they?
Nine out of ten episodes,
they turn, don't they?
And nine out of ten
episodes, at the end
you like them, even if they were
a total jerk in the beginning.
Remember, Ami, the guy in Denver
that I got in a fight with?
He called Chef Duffy "fat boy"?
So I swung at that guy.
I mean, he infuriated me.
We fought for three days.
And he was an
Israeli military guy,
about four feet
four inches tall,
who thought he was
about nine foot tall.
And this guy was an ass.
And what you didn't
see on cameras
before he said fat
boy to Chef Duffy,
he called his
employees assholes.
So my employees are stupid
assholes and your fat boy chef.
I just won't accept robbing
people of their dignity.
I don't do that.
And I'll attack what
you do, but I rarely
attack people personally,
unless it's a unique situation.
Make a long story short,
at the end, he said,
I prayed to God for an angel.
And the angel sent
me Jon Taffer.
So at the end, he
redeemed himself.
And I think that's
why they do it,
is they know at
the end of the show
if they're reasonable at all--
they were jerks along the way,
but at the end,
there's something
endearing about each of them.
I think that's the motivation.
Also, when you're losing
a half a million dollars,
and you've got a
family to support,
that could be pretty
motivating too.
And we do change fortunes.
AUDIENCE: I have two
questions for you.
One is you're very animated.
Your body language is unique.
Have you've studied people
for your own body language?
Is that what you came up with?
Because even on the show, every
move you make seems calculated.
JON TAFFER: It is.
AUDIENCE: And it's very
empowering and brilliant.
JON TAFFER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I just recognize it,
and it's very empowering, just
absolutely shocking
how much you move.
JON TAFFER: Thank you.
And it is.
It is very contrived.
I have to have more energy
than anybody in the room.
I've got to drive the
energy of the TV show,
as well as the five days
for those employees.
So my energy is critical to
moving the process along.
So if I have a flu, if
I have a fever, nope.
I got to be on every day.
I got to lift that energy.
The other thing is
I've got to be loud.
And the fact of the
matter is the things
that you-- back
to your question--
the things that I
say to them have
been said to them
before in many cases.
But when I say it, they are
going to frickin' hear it.
And I'm not going to
allow them not to hear it.
And these animations,
I'm even doing it now,
are really critical
to positioning myself
above them in their perception.
And I don't mean above
as a human being.
They need to look up to me, or
they're not going to follow me.
And the animations, the
energy, the body language,
the communication, the
eye contact, all of this
matters to me getting them to
slip into that submissive role,
if you will, and follow my lead.
AUDIENCE: Your book on
tape should be a video.
JON TAFFER: I have
some videos out.
As a matter of fact, I'm
launching in February Taffer
TV, which we're
launching, I just
built a whole production
studio in Las Vegas
with a 30-foot bar in it.
So it's a whole
educational program
that we're creating to do that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JON TAFFER: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: The second question
was when you rescue a bar,
and these people already
in financial trouble,
does the show pick
up the renovation?
JON TAFFER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does the
show pick up your fees?
Is there ever a deal
that goes on between--
JON TAFFER: The show
pays for everything.
The owner pays for nothing.
AUDIENCE: And they're completely
separate once you leave?
JON TAFFER: Yes, I
have no involvement
in the business when I leave.
As a matter of fact,
probably 80% of them,
I've never spoken
with when I left.
I will share my email with them.
If they have questions,
they can shoot me an email.
I give them my books.
I give them lists of promotions.
They get a binder
about this thick.
And nine out of
ten of them never
communicate with me ever again.
And I don't look back,
to be honest with you.
I'm always looking
forward at the next one.
AUDIENCE: One of the best
things you ever did on the show
was when you brought a previous
"Bar Rescue" owner in to spy
for another one.
That made a big impression.
JON TAFFER: We're doing a
bunch of that this season.
AUDIENCE: I hope so.
JON TAFFER: It's fun
for me, because A, it
gives you an update
on that bar when
they tell you how they're doing.
It shows the relationship
I created with them
that it's real.
And they went through
the experience,
so they're great
candidates to do that.
You're going to see a
lot of that this season.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
JON TAFFER: My pleasure.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So it's actually the last
question we have time for.
Jon, do you have any other
final words or final advice
for some of us?
JON TAFFER: The
only final advice
I would give you is I've lived
a very unconventional life.
And it's because I live
my dream every day.
Dreams are inspiring.
Work is not.
Find a dream.
Whether it's that
client you can't
get that you've been
fighting for six months.
You got to have dreams.
Dreams make this world go on.
It built our whole country.
And when we get in a
rut as human beings
is when we lose touch
with our dreams.
We lose the ability to
fight for those dreams.
So don't be an
employee of Google.
Live your dreams at Google.
Find a way to match your dreams
with the goals of your company
in your own work,
because there's
nothing worse than mechanical
employees that lost touch
with their dream.
The other thing I would
say is leadership.
I'm one of the few
people who say this.
Leadership is not created.
You can read every
leadership book in the world.
I can't make somebody
a leader, if they
weren't by 12 years old.
Leadership is a trait that we
have, that we're born with.
The Pied Piper,
no, you never read
what a good musician
he was, do you?
Couldn't play the flute at
all, but people followed him
off the cliff because of who is.
How many entrepreneurs
do people follow
to bankruptcy that don't
know what they're doing?
Leadership is a
trait that is born.
When you find a great leader,
attach yourself to him.
Ride it to the end,
because great leadership
and your dreams together will
take you to the Promised Land.
And the worst thing
in the world is
when you see somebody who
lost touch with their dreams.
MALE SPEAKER: That's great.
All right, a round of
applause for Jon Taffer.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]